continue d'orienter vers le haut et la
gauche voilà presque bon on y ajoute un
médecin un patient reliés par internet
c'est le principe de la télémédecine en
france elle est autorisée depuis 2010
par décret à l'époque elle est déjà
courante à l'étranger comme en suède
je vais te faire une nouvelle ordonnance
avec deux fois plus de boîtes pour que
ça dure plus en temps mais en france la
pratique ne fait pas l'unanimité ni chez
les médecins
c'est pas un problème de déontologie
c'est un problème de sécurité sanitaire
pour le patient je ne ferai pas de
consultation complète par téléphone
l'iffhs chez des patients ce qui est
essentiel c'est le rapport uma - j'ai
besoin qu effectivement de par herman
docteur qu'ils m'écoutent qu'ils sachent
que je ressens en 2011 sept français sur
dix se disent méfiants face à la
télémédecine
cela dit pour ses défenseurs elle reste
un moyen efficace de lutter contre les
déserts médicaux
est-ce que vous avez médecin dit avec
tout leur honneur votre diabète n'avait
jamais vu un infirmier peut ainsi être
le relais entre un patient isolés ayant
médecin en ville en une demi-heure cette
infirmière fait donc l'équivalent de
cinq consultations de spécialistes
ophtalmologie euros logis podologie elle
réalise les examens dans son camion et
en voit les résultats dans l'espace
grâce à cette parabole depuis 2013 la
télé médecine s'installent dans des
maisons de santé pour les gens qui n'ont
pas permis qui n'ont pas toi tu juges
qui peuvent pas se déplacer
je trouve ces pratiques parce que dans
l'allier il ya plus rien se peut
répondre déjà aux premières questions et
ça peut permettre ensuite aller voir un
spécialiste
donc à deux ou quoi mais au moins on a
déjà tout de suite un premier avis
médical pour qu'elles soient remboursées
il a fallu attendre 2018 selon un
sondage paru avant l'arrivée du coc vide
19 60% des français avaient une bonne
opinion de la télémédecine
il n'était cependant que 6 % à y avoir
déjà eu recours
[Musique]